their job is to nurse and comfort others
but leanne and james have both been
assaulted by patients i was having a
conversation with him the conversation
was absolutely normal he's been pleasant
all day and then he just turned around
and spat in my face
it was in the height of the covered
pandemic i was talking to a colleague
and i suddenly felt a hand um on my
crutch area between my legs to be a
victim of that
for some for me just doing my job for
caring for people is really difficult to
process and justify
such attacks on medical staff are far
from isolated according to new four-year
data supplied by nhs hospital trusts
a sky news freedom of information
request was sent to 150 nhs trusts
76 trusts responded and said they'd
recorded seventy two thousand 174
assaults
half the trust said they'd reported only
3
161 assaults to police
that's 8.6 of all their assaults
of those trusts 23 kept a record of
police action in their cases
they had nearly 19 000 assaults they
referred
1289 to police
and only 458 resulted in a police
caution or a court hearing
the decision to report an assault isn't
always straightforward
when the patient spat at james he didn't
tell police
on that occasion i didn't
pursue
any um charges gentlemen was at the end
of his life and confused it went through
my head that i didn't want his wife to
be contacted you know after he died
maybe a week later by the police to be
found out that was
the last memory of her husband
the government told us it was working to
protect nhs staff from violent patients
and others and ensure quick and
effective punishment
it is shocking and we're seeing
increasing numbers now where nhs staff
face abuse and aggression
in the workplace i think it's important
to put into context though that
sometimes these patients could be unwell
particularly mental health problems the
bma has actually called on the
government to increase the penalty for
common assault from one to two years
for nhs staff and public sector workers
and we're waiting for them to act on
that
is there a sense that some staff see
assault as an occupational hazard some
people may say
it's part of the job but actually no i
don't i don't i don't believe it is any
form of assault verbal
or violence and aggression
is not acceptable
and it doesn't just affect hospital
staff
a recent poll of uk family doctors
revealed three out of four had faced a
rise in verbal abuse or aggression
during the coronavirus pandemic
martin brunt sky news bournemouth